The Joe Rogan Experience when the UFC
came on the scene it's like look at you
Jitsu [__] everything else yeah so then
then also and everything started coming
back around so that's when long was like
told you [__] so
um
look at this oh my God this is all
thanks to Ray Lana oh look at that right
hand dude this was the craziest you had
some crazy power Matt Sarah I'm sure you
still do but you really did then dude
look at that boom nuts boom I mean it
was freaky power it was one of those
things where like watching George tap
the strikes yeah in this situation I
mean this was a wild wild upset not a
house full of people the crazy thing was
you know again you were known as the Jiu
Jitsu Champion you were known as one of
the best Jiu Jitsu guys ever to come out
of America so if do you for you to see
you knocking guys out like that was wild
when I had to fight thank you first of
all thanks when I had to fight Carol
Parisian uh
I took the fight and I was I was healthy
but when I first got the call a few
weeks before that a couple weeks before
that I had a torn meniscus so when they
asked me I'm like I go I could I could
run I go defeat the floor didn't feel
good the wrestling I couldn't do so I I
felt like it's going to tear off I did
that but I could do some Jiu Jitsu I
could run and I could box
so we did a lot of boxing for that he
would Ray would and I think that truly
helped me because it got it's weird
because I got tired in that fight and I
very rarely get tired and I truly
believe it's because I did not mimic the
fight with defeat the floor sparring
right so you know when that's a that's a
that's a different kind of win that you
need to do it it's like wrestling it's
up and down up and down and I didn't
have that and I got one of my few times
in my career I got winded and it was
Cairo
one of the he's probably one of the
worst guys to get winded with because
that [__] had a good gas tank so
I almost knocked him out in the
beginning because all that boxing play I
used to not bad hands with that [__]
thing and I was really getting used to
Rolling and coming back and landing and
Longo was happy with it he was taking me
in the Brooklyn to work at Lou neglia's
school too in Brooklyn and I was getting
fresh faces and I was really starting to
feel good and get the timing in that I
never had with the with the stand up so
where I [__] up with I had him hurt
I had him up against the [__] thing
he got a [__] Judo grip inside my
[__] pants you see me go to the ref
he's got a grip and by that time he
weathered it
still had to shoot my load got tired it
went the way it went that got me into
the tough house which led to good things
but two things the one when I got him
hurt I didn't line that [__] up you know
what I'm saying I was just [__] so
when I heard George he Longo pointed to
that he goes when you heard him
manage your distance keep your distance
manage and line it up and that's what we
did and a couple of things long ago had
me doing with the he had me having a
[__] ball like a medicine ball kind
of it was a rubber but it was heavy and
you'd have me just throw it after each
during the circuit training even if the
sparring 25 times that's his [__]
head dude
really made me believe that that could
[__] stand with this guy he goes they
think you're going to try to get them
down you're not going to try to get them
down and I remember looking at that Jeff
Munson fight that's cemented it I go
dude did you wasn't going to do that
right I'm not doing that I'm not gonna
do that I go I'm so I didn't know I was
gonna knock him out but I knew that I
had a very good chance of doing it
because I was hurting guys with the 60
ounce gloves and you know long goes like
look man he's [__] had any he goes to
standing up he's doing some karate [__]
it's not that big listen he's like I
love George and he's better at the stuff
he was doing standing at the time Longo
had guys feeding me the exact [__] it
was weird it was some Matrix [__]
because then in the fight I remember at
one point he did a high kick a low kick
a high kick I remember just being like
Oh I feel like Spider-Man
so it just it was a good it felt like a
good day of sparring you know wow and by
the way everybody out there don't watch
the rematch
when when you went into the rematch were
you injured
the word was before the rematch Matt had
hurt his back and that I had heard that
you'd hurt your back well the thing is
this I this is what happened I was
supposed to fight
Matt Hughes right and and that's when
you hurt your back I hurt my back yeah
and then I was out
and then that's when they fought Matt
this is New Year's Eve so this was New
Year's Eve when I was out on my back
so they fought New Year's Eve I know
because we did a watch party at MSG you
know and they fought so I didn't know
who I was fighting at that point so then
I had my back was out so then George
beat Matt so now I was fighting George I
was gonna fight Matt that's my first
title defense
so now
I was gonna fight George and then I
forgot so my back was out on what is
that uh the 31st of so this is the very
injury you were talking about right the
very same injury I talked about earlier
because I was supposed to fight no
yes yes that is the that is the same
injury I was supposed to fight Matt I
ain't been fighting Matt eventually
right but that's what it was I'm trying
to think of the timeline so this was the
December
uh what is it 20 31st new that's when
they fought
so that I had to fight George in April
so this month's there for me to but I
had to go through a camp yeah but if you
have herniated discs and you go to your
chiropractor
yeah you're making it worse
I wasn't walking then but I ended up
getting the weight off and and and you
weren't being able to fight I wasn't I
wasn't well I was walking but how about
this when I'm when you bend over to
brush your teeth I wasn't able to do
this
for how long
it was Doctor my thought my my black
belt Dr Yasha I'm giving him a shout out
because he gave me an epidural
you had two epidurals before that fight
I didn't want to say it unless you well
he gave that to me in I guess January
that just kills the pain it got I don't
know what it did exactly but it got me
back it got me back to being what does
that do an epidural it's just it's more
of it it's a surgery thing it does not
always work either you know it helped me
I was I was afraid I wasn't coming back
and he got me back you know but that's
what they what they do with women
provides anesthesia that creates a band
of numbness from your belly button to
your upper legs it allows you to be
awake and alert through Labor okay so
but it's also it's not that there's also
an epidural for uh back batteries but
girl Google that epidural back injuries
it must be like some sort of a pain
epidural there it is
um blocker so it was in January yeah so
there it is right there Cleveland
epidural steroid injections yeah so uh
anesthesia's injection injecting
anesthetic into the epidural spine
around your spine so it could stop pain
signals so that's what it is
but your back is still weak yeah it's
still [__] up 100 did it affect your
movement with the epidural no listen I'm
gonna this is what I want you to say
this because you're just making an
excuse I'm just asking you as a human
being like what was it like
I'm gonna say this is what I'll say the
epidural it took me a little bit to get
back into into being able to train
properly but you got to think
I got to that fight I got I got I it
wasn't my [__] best my best uh camp
but I got there and I showed up and I
took my shot and I and I signed the
dotted line and I feel George was so on
point that night
what a [__] night that was too man
that was [__] 50 000.
Longo doesn't speak quietly I couldn't
hear him in between rounds chance of
[__] you Sarah
you know what it was it was around the
time of um Talladega Nights
where I go he should just drink his red
wine and shut the [__] up but I was
doing some some Michael Frost called him
Frenchy but it was all from the movie of
course and I loved George and it was uh
it was you know I was a kid too it was
you know whatever it was but my I feel
George was so on point that night that
if I had my even if I was in [__] Tip
Top I think I probably would it probably
would have resembled him and and and and
Nick Diaz with me like survive I didn't
like that I got I stopped you know what
I mean that that that tortured me a
matter of fact when I was gonna fight
Frank Trigg there was pictures of Frank
Triggs face photoshopped on George
saying I remember reading a thing who
else thinks that Frank Trig's gonna
wrestle [__] Sarah
anyway uh
uh so just like I told KRON I I had to
get I had to kick somebody else's ass
because I didn't like the way that
second fight went it felt horrible